More than 2 billion Covid-19
vaccines administered worldwide.
Halfway vaccinated!
I'm getting the Moderna..
AstraZeneca shot.
J&J vaccine.
As millions get vaccinated, many reunions
are happening around the country.
It's been a very long time
and so much life has happened
You're gonna have the best night
you've had for a very long time.
We've all been through something collectively.
It's been such a difficult time.
And it's even harder pretending like
everything's normal when it's not.
700,000 people quit retail jobs... as the
so-called Great Resignation picked up speed.
They just didn't care about me anymore.
There is not a shortage of jobs,
there is a shortage of decent jobs.
The shortage of products has
extended to just about everything.
Big shortage of lumber
Shortage of snowblowers...
And a shortage of microchips.
Look at those bones!
Can you not. please?
The growing backlog in the global supply chain...
A giant container ship wedged from bank to bank.
Verstappen and Hamilton have crashed.
Messi has done it.
Guys on Reddit get rich off GameStop while
bankrupting a bunch of hedge funds.
It's been a fun ride with GameStop.
A few things I am not: I'm not a cat.
It just shows how much power the rich people have.
What is an NFT... sold for
nearly 70 million dollars.
Literally sending Dogecoin to the moon.
Anyone with enough money can become an astronaut.
Looking down to our beautiful, beautiful earth.
We need some of the world's greatest brains
fixed on trying to repair this planet,
not trying to find the next place to go and live.
The report is very clear: we expect to see new
extremes that are unprecedented in magnitude,
timing, or in regions that have never
encountered those types of extremes.
The most affected people in the most
affected areas still remain unheard.
Myanmar has been under political
chaos since a junta-led military coup
ousted the elected government.
Farmers in India are marking a year since they
began the biggest protest in
the country's modern history.
The deadly conflict between Israeli
forces and Palestinians continues
The government of Ethiopia has
been locked in a year-long war
with the Tigray People's Liberation Front.
A sudden wave of thousands of migrants has sparked
a humanitarian crisis at the US-Mexico border.
How can you do that to a human
being, to other human beings?
It's time for American troops to come home.
It's a very very crazy situation right now.
They broke the glass in the United States Capitol
and now they are climbing through the window...
... the world is watching in horror...
We will never give up, we will never concede.
These people coordinated on open parts of
the internet: on Instagram, on Facebook.
These platforms are not merely mirroring humanity.
They're making all of us our worst selves.
I am proud to announce that starting
today, our company is now Meta.
People really underestimate
the power of misinformation.
People who've had these
shots, and now they're magnetized.
This is becoming a pandemic of the unvaccinated.
People haven't related to it. You see the figures,
the daily figures, and they're nameless faces.
India is being ravaged by...
a second wave of Covid-19 is
threatening to overwhelm the
country's health systems.
We don't have anything, and patients are dying.
Vaccine inequality cannot be allowed to continue.
Omicron is spreading at a rate we have
not seen with any previous variant.
The more this virus spreads, the more likely
it is for a very dangerous variant to emerge.
We're in this together, and the only
way we're going to conquer this virus
is by working together.
They've agreed to share the gold medal.
Just because you're a female, it doesn't mean
you can't accomplish the biggest of goals.
The Philippines first-ever Olympic gold medal.
Put your mental health first, it doesn't
matter if you're on the biggest stage.
That's more important than
any other medal you could win.
There's so many people who are
afraid to voice that they need help.
To truly choose to love is heroic.
Chile's congress has passed a bill
allowing same-sex couples to marry.
Britney Spears is free.
Hardly any of these police ever go to prison.
We the jury find the defendant guilty.
I'm so happy. I'm so so happy right now.
With the Asian-American community, enough
is enough, we're just fed up.
What I really hope that this movie can
do is show Asian kids that it's okay to
take up space where they are, because they belong.
I know where I'm headed in life, I know
what my future is going to look like.
When something says "Taylor's
version," that means I own it!
Rock and roll never dies!
There are people who don't believe
that women can be better presidents,
and we are here to show them.
Taking its first steps in pursuit of
cosmological discovery... touchdown confirmed.
We did not feel prepared to be the
heirs of such a terrifying hour.
But within it we found the power to author a new
chapter, to offer hope and laughter to ourselves.
So, while once we asked, how could we
possibly prevail over catastrophe, now
we assert, how could catastrophe
possibly prevail over us?